some sort of package to help with actual
bills because it's fine saying that
they're capping the uh the energy you
know with the energy price cap but the
more needed to be done in terms of
actually offering people help with bills
and existing fuel debt okay it's a very
good point Jack I'll tell you I'm going
to bring in Gemma and Greg now it is a
good point isn't it because there has
been a package of measures but still the
cost of living is is still very very
high isn't it great it is and of course
while it's true as Jack says that the
government's capped the energy price
guarantee so cost of energy won't be
going up any further than it already has
the energy bill support scheme is coming
to an end now and so that 400 pounds
that every household received over the
course of the six previous months is
finishing at exactly the same time as
the price is capped so in practice what
many households like Jacks are going to
experience over the next few months is
actually that it will feel like energy
has gone up in price because the end of
that ebss scheme is coincided with this
budget so it's a mixed picture and by by
no means is this an easy time for
households even though we are hoping to
see energy bills come down towards the
end of the year as prices start to fall
down what would you say to Jack I mean I
think it is a really tough time because
what we're seeing is that the majority
people's income is being spent on food
and fuel and because energy costs are
going up it also means food prices are
also going up so this really is a really
big impact so absolutely underneath the
headline of you know the energy price
guarantee being frozen taking away that
support that 67 pound a month does mean
that for people where their bills are
around you know that are really going to
feel that big increase I think yeah and
Jack we're told that inflation is going
to fall so that hopefully does mean
price is coming down at some point is
that kind of any silver lining for you
I guess it is in the long term but
obviously in the short term uh you know
that's that's like saying that people
will carry on breathing
um it's it's it doesn't offer any sort
of stability uh and not knowing whether
you're actually going to be able to
cover all of your bills in the month
it's it's really hard
yeah I'm sure it is Jack we we
appreciate your thoughts thank you so
much for joining us and then the best of
luck with the year ahead of you
um let's bring another corner now uh
Helen is joining us now Helen's joining
in from Dorset this evening Helen it's
great to have you on the program and so
when it comes to energy bills and also
fuel bills what kind of what's your
position and what did you think of what
you heard today from Jeremy Hunt
I I don't in terms of few fuel wheels
Etc I don't think it's any good news at
all essentially we've still got the
height that we got
um since the Autumn catastrophe I mean
the reason I called in today if you
don't mind me saying is I was absolutely
appalled at the delivery in Parliament
today from both sizes of the house but
mainly from the conservative benches
where they they were trying to get in my
mind some Glory statements out there
from a situation they've actually caused
um the focus on getting people back to
work is is good but essentially how are
they going to get find talented
motivated people to come into roles that
are essential so roles within the
education sector within the medical
sector when right at the moment that
they were promising extra breakfast
clubs after school clubs to get people
back to work I think are actually going
to fill those roles because essentially
as he was making that promise those
people those hard-working people that
are funding with their own money
stationary for schools Etc are on strike
because they can't afford the problems
with the rise in gas bills with the rise
in mortgage prices they can't afford to
do their day-to-day job so how are they
going to find these hungry people to
fill those promises of child care
education
Etc and the fact that they were laughing
and joking the whole way through the
delivery of the budget I found a polling
and wouldn't expect seeing any business
environment so for our government to
speak like that to make whip that the
deputy speaker I just I found the whole
delivery of the budget irrespective of
the policies they were promising
just embarrassing for from a UK
government point of view good point
Helen thank you so much let's bring
Gemma in now I think you're nodding away
with that didn't work yeah and the
delivery as well because he talks about
Asia you mentioned the deputy speaker
and I think that didn't go down very
well no I don't I don't think it did I
mean I think the main point he was
trying to make is that people that are
older have more experience and
absolutely should be encouraged to have
the same working opportunities
um a colleague of mine has been saying
that it's it's not about going from the
office chair to the armchair you know
people do really want to stay engaged in
the in the workforce but I think what's
been hidden in the budget is the fact
what we heard from the office of budget
responsibility is that we're still going
to have another tough two years is that
in real terms
um disposable income is going to
continue to fall so for every 100 pounds
that you have today you're going to have
94 pounds in two years time and the two
things that were missing from the budget
which absolutely has been picked up on
um was number one what's happening with
the public sector pay and secondly
what's happening to people who because
of inflation because they're being
pulled up things are costing more and
potentially maybe they've got a small
pay rise if they're lucky you know know
they're suddenly going into a higher tax
bracket which means naturally they're
then paying more tax so you know there
isn't any support for people that are
really being squeezed that are just
about managing and I think it's going to
be a really tough time absolutely in
terms of fuel energy food and essential
goods and it's great to have you know
child support but I agree with you this
is a really serious issue more people
are being pulled into poverty and it's
still a very very tricky time especially
when we're here for the next two years
is going to be tricky Helen thank you so
much for that I'm going to come to Greg
just a few minutes time because I want
to bring in Joseph now who's A qualier
from Southern coalfield Jose I think
you're going to be our youngest caller
this evening you're 16 years old yeah so
welcome we're very delighted to have you
on the program I I I I understand that
you're a labor supporter but you're
you've actually been impressed by the
budget so unlike Helen what did he make
of what you heard today I have in terms
of what could have been said and what
we've seen been said in recent budgets I
do see it as a positive
um what's the cartoon is I've been
advocating for a lot of mental health
um
support under 10 million pound that
Jeremy Hunt said will go into Suicide
Prevention really really impressed me
today
um also the the raised in defense
spending how we can look into the camera
and promise not of no recession and even
a 1.8 growth increase in the economy
next year did a lot did impression
okay would it would it has it impressed
enough to change your votes yet if you
don't mind me asking
well it is hard to trust the Tory and B
in in recent times I will say it won't
be changing my vote obviously on I'm 16.
so in the coming years I probably will
be still right
I'll still probably still will be voting
labor but right okay interesting though
really really interesting point of view
Greg what do you think I'm fascinated by
this this real tension between the
experience that many people are having
but we know that if you look at sort of
the rates of fuel poverty what's
happening people Obsession on Lower
incomes right now how how large a
proportional people's incomes are being
absorbed by paying for food as Gemma
says paying for energy bills and the
tension between that and this kind of
jock killer joking tone in Parliament a
lot of I think a lot of Jeremy Hunt's
jokes might have gone very down very
well in Parliament but probably don't go
down very well
across the country at large and
certainly this afternoon you know our
sound was in Burnley talking to people
and they were not impressed either by
the tone or the substance so it's good
to know that some people are impressed
by some of those more symbolic measures
like the the increase in defense
spending and the the allocation of more
resources to mental health and of course
we have to welcome those as we do things
like the child care initiatives that
were announced today but there is this
real challenge a lot of households are
so hard up at the moment that it's
really hard to listen to those positive
of messages when you're really filling
the pinch Joseph thank you so much for
your call we're going to go straight now
to Lucy she's calling in from Stratford
upon Ava and uh Lucy what did you make
of what you heard today
um I just think they're very out of
touch rmp is Nadine's the Harvey
um and obviously he's had all these tax
irregularities in January he's a
multi-millionaire and I don't really
understand how he can stay in touch with
us you know food inflation's up 16 my
bills are up 26 and I live on my own so
I don't have someone else paying half
the bills and I'm just wondering when
it's going to go down
what would you like to have heard I mean
what could what could make your life
better would you say
um I get 25 off my council tax bill for
being single but I really think it
should be 50 but I think the main
problem is until this war ends in
Ukraine and Gas and energy goes back to
normal hopefully I don't think it's it's
going to end it's just going up and up
and up
okay let's see if we can get some help
or some advice Lucy uh from both our
experts who are in the get in the studio
here I mean General is there anything
that people can do right now borrowing
what the government was saying today I
mean what the government is hoping for
is that come July Energy prices are
going to be falling and we started to
see that come come off
um obviously then we also enter the
summer people are using less heat to be
able to you know warm their homes as
well so hopefully there will be a bit of
a respite come the summer but just
coming back to the point that was made
there is a tax on single people it's not
a 50 if you are on your own you know
people that are in couples they do have
certain tax breaks and also they have a
lot of their costs that they can split
with somebody else so I agree that there
should be especially when people are you
know single parents as well you know
having an extra level of support I think
is going to be really important so you
know look as with everything it's always
a case of listen out see how read the
fine print of what's been announced
today see if there isn't any support
further support coming especially around
you know when people have children
around child minders
um but I do think that if people are on
their own right now now it is it is very
hard and just trying to get to the
summer is going to be um the focus Greg
I was just looking earlier on today you
know suicide rates have risen by three
percent since the start of the cost of
living crisis and things like the
squeeze on people's energy bills the
cost of food these aren't costs you
can't get away from I mean turning the
heat off is just not an option in a cold
weather spell particularly if people who
are elderly or people who are infirm or
people with younger children so look the
reality is this is a very tough time for
many households it's going to be tough
even if inflation comes down inflation
of course is a measure of the rate at
which prices increase but even if
inflation does fall as much as the
chancellor has said that they're hoping
it will down below three percent by the
end of the year three percent inflation
still means prices are going up but just
less quickly than they have been so
there's a lot of pain and suffering
still to come is the government doing
enough or the government's trying to say
that it's doing enough but while
inflation remains so high and crucially
while tax thresholds aren't increasing
even though earnings are increasing
households are still getting squeezed
and as Gemma Sedonia are on the obr's
data says that we they have never had in
the history of their of their data
reporting such a sharp squeeze on
household budgets that's briefly yeah
just very briefly just very quickly
um savings rates are going up so you can
actually earn a little bit of interest
on your money and I'd say just trying to
make your money it's tiny bit okay Lucy
thank you very much really good point
there and we're going to continue with
the scene with the cost of living of
course and energy prices I'd like to
bring in Anastasia now Anastasia you're
calling from London I know Anastasia you
have cerebral palsy you've got an awful
lot on your plate as well uh tell us
kind of your situation and what you
thought today and what you'd like to
hear yes I do have a thank you uh hello
I do have an awful lot on my plate and
it and it's true I've got cerebral palsy
and other health conditions I would also
like to see a copy of the disability
white paper and it is true I don't I
really don't believe that people should
laugh
um when it comes to finances it's just
um not appropriate some people with
disabilities
um it's very it's very complicated I
mean the money that we had previously is
not is it really isn't sufficient I mean
electric beds uh electric wheelchairs
people you know Machinery to stay alive
it's just really really difficult and
also this is something else
unfortunately I I actually have a care
background as well so um I don't have
any relatives so I don't have any
network whatsoever so things are
incredibly
difficult for difficult for me I I just
we'll see what happens in reality
um I'd like to get into politics if I
had the opportunity to try and make some
changes good for you that's what the
country is people like you I mean just
very quickly the two issues he did
really focus on when it comes to
disability work of abolishing the work
capability assessment for disability
people disabled or disabilities I should
say and the launch of universal support
I suppose this is a scheme to try and
get people with disabilities into the
workforce if they want to
um is that something you'd be interested
in it's something I would be interested
in but
the system is not not sorry
um it's very difficult to navigate and
and sometimes it's just platitude you
know we we need to go beyond words and
and have some action but I think it's a
good idea to test systems out to test
the reality because I would like to say
there's an advert on TV that's doing uh
circulation
okay Anastasia tell you what let's bring
in our experts now um Greg you've been
nodding in in agreement there very
powerful story from Anastasia what would
you like to see it is so look I mean we
heard today about the universal support
scheme this new scheme which supposedly
will make up to 4 000 pounds available
for disabled people who are seeking to
return to the workforce or enter the
Workforce Now how will that work who who
will it be applicable to and of course
not all people in the situation are able
to return to the workforce I very much
hope given Anastasia your Lucidity and
articulously I very much hope that
support scheme is available to help you
go into politics because clearly you
know voices like yours aren't being
heard enough and I think it's great that
you have that you have that interest and
let's hope that schemes like this work
and that's I think the proof will be in
the pudding over the next over the next
few years Gemma very briefly did you
want to come in I think the thing that
was good in the budget was trying to
separate out somebody's ability to work
with somebody's eligibility for benefits
which means that people that are
disabled have certain you know health or
issues are still confident enough to be
to try and search for work and not feel
like it's going to endanger the benefits
that they absolutely need okay Gemma
thank you very much and just as a quick
reminder you can still call in the
number is
0208167-2200 so call in within this next
hour and we'll do our best to get you on
to onto the air and talk to our experts
if you've got any views or comments
regarding today's statement now talking
about today's announcements the
chancellor also had a very big thing to
say about child care working parents in
England will be able to get free child
care for children ages nine months and
above from September 2025 so you've got
to wait a little bit it's a move aimed
to get more parents back into the
workplace is the plan deliverable though
let's get your views I'm delighted to
say Sharon joins us now this evening
Sharon you're calling in from Southwest
London so you're just around the corner
from where we are now what did you make
of what you heard about child care today
hi and thank you so I think that any
Improvement in the budget is solely
needed and very welcome but I I'm really
disappointed that this support isn't
coming past enough so as you said the
the real support to parents uh is two
and a half years away it's September 25
that they'll get the 30 hours of child
care from children nine months old and
above and the worry for me is that means
women will continue to be locked out of
the workforce because they can't afford
Child Care an estimated half a million
to 1.7 million mothers are locked out
already and so we're going to miss out
on the economic contribution that these
women could make at a time that the
economy needs that contribution and at a
time when employers have skill gaps and
roles that they can't fill so I'm
disappointed about the budget uh Sharon
Jeremy Hunt says he said delayed a
little bit so so the system can catch up
so capacity can be created and you get
Nursery places does that wash with you
and I do understand that because you
can't open up the numbers when the
supply isn't there one of the real
issues at the moment is adequate supply
of child care but I do think he could
bring forward the support to child care
providers earlier providers and it's
staggered at the moment part will come
in September part will come next year he
could bring that forward to this year so
that we could get a bit of a head start
in sorting out the supply issues so
let's bring in Greg and Gemma get their
views as well I mean Greg This was meant
to be the big rabbit wasn't it the
rabbit out the hat that kind of got
leaked the day before we think in terms
of issues of child care I mean china
Rose is a good point once you dig into
it it's actually a bit more complicated
than the headline suggests and it's
phased exactly as Sharon says so yes by
September 25 this support will be
available for those younger children one
or two it's already available of course
for three and four year olds but it will
be extended to younger children
um this is important so the the group
pregnant then screwed estimates that one
in four working mothers spend more than
75 percent of their income on Child Care
at the moment most expensive in in
Europe the most expensive child care in
any major economy uh in Europe and so
you know it's a situation where there
are very limited incentives for mums to
go back into the workplace after they
had their children and so look clearly
this is the right direction to travel I
think there'll be very few people who
would challenge that why it's going to
take so long to implement and what can
be done in the meantime I don't know and
it's a shame that we're not seeing this
happen even sooner but at least we can
welcome that it is happening Gemma what
do you think I think also if you look
into the fine print which is obviously
the most important thing there are a
couple of restrictions around as we know
it's only going to be available to
people where everybody in the household
Works a minimum of 16 hours
um a week but also you've also got um
it's only going to apply for 36 weeks of
the year most people work for at least
48 weeks of the year and the third thing
is the wrap around care obviously is
only going to be available then during
term time which still doesn't help with
school holidays now I don't be too
negative on it because I think it is a
big Leap Forward
but it does mean that there's a huge
amount of issues that need to be worked
out to really give the support that
people are going to need a leap forward
but some issues there um Sharon thank
you we really appreciate your thoughts
we're also going to invite Julie uh in
to join us now Julie you're calling in
from West Yorkshire I know you've also
got a really good point to make tonight
and that's regarding child minders where
they are sorely myth aren't they as a
Workforce in this country right now
what's the point you'd like to make
um there's a couple of points I'd like
to make my daughter's a teacher Works
full-time and I'm I look after her
little boy who's two years old and she
will never get any films until me
because you can't get funding for a
family member
which I think's been missed somewhere
because she would have to send him to
another setting to be able to get the
funding she should have to move in from
me to another settings even when it gets
to three and four year old
yeah that's a really good point I tell
you what I reckon we could try and get
some help for you on that Julie um so if
you're a family member and you're caring
for you for you for your grandchild or
you know a niece or nephew what is the
situation we're being paid as a child
minder well I mean there isn't that's
the problem is that it's really targeted
on the parent it's interesting because I
so I do some research on this because
um one in four families actually rely on
their parents so the grandparents to
look after their children and really the
only thing that's in place is there's
something known as um transferring your
National Insurance credits to your to
the grandparents but if you do that it's
just a transfer it's not additional
support
um and again I wouldn't be recommending
that I'm just saying that's the only
thing that's in play at the moment so I
think you know what we heard today is
that there's going to be payments made
for people that decide to become child
minders and so 600 pounds or you know
double that amount of it's done through
an agency so hopefully that will
increase the amount because we've seen
it we've seen the number of child
minders fall by about nine percent
um you know over the last year or so and
they are a flexible affordable way to be
able to help people get back to work
which is really important
um but really when it comes to
grandparents are such a good source of
care there isn't enough support that's
there really
um Julie has I answered your questions
being ideally what would you like to
happen well I'm not a grandparent just
grandpa I am a leadership seven years
myself right yeah so I've got other
children in my care I've got you know
so I'm doing it as a child mind and not
as a grandparent but you can't get the
funding
but you can't get the funding Greg you'd
like to bring in it's just going to last
so the other thing we've heard about is
this increase in minimum Staffing ratios
from one to four to one to five and the
idea being of course that if you
increase the Staffing ratios it will
enable child minders to take on more
children at the same time so I was just
interested to ask Julie whether whether
you have any opinions about whether
that's likely to Be an Effective move
no so don't
forget the ratios are right oh they are
I think we need to keep the quality of
care there so the ratios you think
should stay the same but you're looking
for more funding I think the funding
should be if you're not just a
grandparent and you are doing it as a
business you've got other children on
law then grandparents should be allowed
to get the access to funding for their
grandchildren
Julie thank you thank you very much uh
really good points that you've been
making there let's also speak now to
Julie who's joining us from Southwestern
London I believe
um no Connie excuse me we've spoken to
Judy already Connie uh welcome to the
program you are calling from Southwest
London this evening
um and yeah great to have you on the
program what did you think about the
child care package that was introduced
today it was it was something quite
positive and we were looking forward to
it when when it was all leaked out that
there was going to be
free child care my daughter was very
excited because she's on maternity leave
at the moment her baby's six months old
but of course when it all boils down to
it this won't really kick in for her
until September 2025 which seems a long
way off
the positive step but it's just a shame
that it's going to take all that time I
mean we're talking about children that
are that are not even born at the moment
so I as a grandparent I've helped my son
out in the past with with child care
when his children were younger but my
daughter lives in the Midlands and I've
even considered would I sell up and and
go and live there to try and help them
that's a very drastic step
I I feel disappointed and I think it's
it's positive thing but I just wish it
would come into Force just that quicker
because you know September 2025 is is a
long way off and from September 24 is
only 15 hours that will be available to
extend it to all children from nine
months old
so again sorry instructor Connor you say
that your your daughter is Keen to get
back to work but the moment she can't or
she's you know it is she's on maternity
leave at the moment that she'll be going
back to work shortly
but she'll only go back part-time
because the child care costs are so so
high you know she should be working for
virtually nothing and having sort of two
hours Journey every day which he's
willing to do but it just seems so
unfair when when you've you've got a job
you're Keen to get back to it you want
to do what's right by your child as well
and then obstacles are in your way and
as I say we were so pleased to hear
about this 30 hours we were over the
moon but of course the downside is that
it's not it won't kick in for quite
and I just feel
it is quite urgent and you know when
people are willing to go to work and
people are needed in their jobs
the path should be made clear for them
to do that yeah Connie very eloquently
put thank you so much I'm sure your
grandchildrenal or grandchild will be
will be pretty grown up in a couple of
years time why won't they but um and
this is this is a really good point
isn't it Gemma this um you know for
children who were maybe not even born
yet this is this is kind of who they're
focusing on over the next couple of
years absolutely the the lag is the big
problem is that this isn't going to come
really soon enough for so many
hard-working families
um if you think about it you know we
need to get more people back working
into the economy as well there's a huge
Talent shortage you know these are
people that very very highly skilled
that want to go back to work and it's a
real shame that it's going to take so
long we know the reason why they the
government said that it's because there
needs to be allowed to encourage to let
the supply catch up with the demand
um but still there were other things
that could have been done um to really
help that especially as we saw that
there is support for child minders you
know again if there's more incentive to
get people to go back and work in
nurseries then potentially you could
have actually accelerated the supply
issue to match the demands and had a
solution sooner so my heart goes out
because I think it's a real shame to
have somebody that really wants to work
and just can't because of child care
issues okay Gemma thank you so much Greg
thank you too you're staying with us
you're not going anywhere because we've
got more callers coming up in a few
minutes time after this short break
December
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you hi there welcome back a very
good evening to you you're watching the
budget you're saying and we are taking
your calls today about today's budget
and answering your points with our
experts Greg Marsh and Gemma Godfrey who
are in the studio primed with all their
facts and figures to try and help you
out a little bit just to let you know
0208167-2200 is a number for you to call
do you get your calls in as soon as you
can and we'll do our best to get you on
air this evening right up until eight
o'clock tonight well let's now talk
about the government's plans to grow the
economy by boosting businesses and their
workers now we heard the chance to talk
an awful lot about the economic inactive
today and his attempts to get more
people back into the workforce I think
he cited the one million plus job
vacancies that are out there at the
moment would love to get your calls on
that and in fact we've got Nick who's
calling in right now from Sheffield and
Nick I understand that you're a small
business owner and you've certainly got
concerns about that and also about the
strike action that we saw mass strike
action today what would you like to see
I certainly are saying Center yeah I
think for me it you know the
government's trying to get more people
into work but we've got a sort of a
massive amount of people that are
currently striking and I was quite
saddened not to hear anything in the
budget that was maybe fortunate for them
um I think we would have a much stronger
economy if all the strikes were not
happening and the economy could to a
position of being able to recover from
all the strike action that we've seen
over the last few months
um it was quite disappointing that there
wasn't anything in there Strikers
Nick you make you make a really good
point I noticed that too actually that
there was given that there was a great
protest outside Westminster I think it
was the biggest industrial action to
date where teachers we know NHS doctors
tube Strikers and yet nothing really on
strike action from Jeremy Hunt did that
surprise you too Greg well Jeremy Hunt's
contention is that this is really about
inflation right the reason that there is
labor dispute industrial turmoil is
because inflation is so high it's
therefore to hear the government make
the case it's impossible to raise
earnings as much as inflation's
increased and that's what puts pressure
on people's living standards so if you
believe that this budget is going to
help bring inflation down rather than
that mainly being due to Market forces
and things like Energy prices falling
then I guess the government is trying to
help but it's trying to help indirectly
um I suppose if you don't believe that
if you don't think that these budget
measures are going to reduce inflation
then yes you know this is sort of the
elephant in the room that Jeremy Hunt
doesn't want to talk talk about Gemma
what do you say the big issue that we
have is that the price of or the price
of living is going up so much faster
than wages and to not hear anything at
all about raising public sector wages
was actually real shock I mean there was
a rumor that he was going to come out
with I think it was a five percent or a
certain level which wouldn't have
actually surprised markets because
that's very reasonable given how much
the price of living has actually risen
so it was a real a shock and a shame
that there isn't enough support there
okay Nick we appreciate your thoughts
tonight then Nick joining us from
Sheffield let's join uh Charlotte now
Charlotte you're calling him from London
uh you're an NHS doctor uh and so an
awful lot to talk to you about what did
you make of the views and the the uh
Jeremy Hunt's uh uh budget today
as well I found the budget overall
greatly disappointing from both
perspectives that the NHS seems to have
been completely ignored it's sad but
from a very personal perspective and I
know that I share this with many of my
colleagues the NHS just doesn't work in
a way that we've all been terminally
proud of for so very long and
essentially to have sidelined this and
not not made it a priority in any sense
is really disappointing morale is at an
all-time low not just amongst doctors
but the whole Healthcare Workforce their
sector is hemorrhaging employees and
naturally patients are frustrated too I
have been myself recently and and this
has just been ignored in you know
in this budget almost completely
yeah and our previous caller made a very
good point as well about about that in
terms of strike action I mean what what
could he say to make things better for
you what would you like to hear as a as
a doctor but also as a as a um a patient
at the NHS
that's a great question and and and it's
not an easy you know it's not an easy
answer a question to answer
um pay increases need to happen across
the board and I'm not just saying that
as a doctor but I I fully support nurses
and public sector workers across the
board but we also need to maintain the
workforce that we have and part of that
is pay but also conditions
um lots of people don't know but getting
annual leave as a doctor is almost
impossible people can't get time off for
their own weddings let alone a honeymoon
or anything like that which you know
there's just basic things that keep your
morale up and make you feel valued as an
as a member of an organization as an
employee
okay Charlotte thank you I'll tell you
what let's bring in Gemma and Greg now
um it is interesting Greg because we
didn't hear anything about the police
anything about the NHS we heard very
little about house building all these
areas of budgets normally are kind of
jam-packed with
um what do you think of that
my sister is a GP so I get this I get
this at weekends from here and I think
look there's no question right NHS
workers have had an enormously tough 18
months that's one of the reasons why for
the first time I can recall we're seeing
NHS workers on strike I mean that's an
extraordinary idea the idea that people
in such a critical role would see the
need to take to the streets so there's
clearly a lot of sentiment about this
and I like Gemma was disappointed and
surprised that there wasn't more direct
intervention here but on the other hand
again I'm not here to defend the
government's record about this I think
what Jeremy Hunt would say is that you
can't increase salaries without fueling
inflation and so if it's or if the real
ill here or the evil is to try to temper
inflation then that's why the government
feels tension on this issue the only
measure we did here which arguably helps
a certain number of NHS workers is
potentially the change to pension
provision to allow those older NHS
workers on higher salaries create the
incentives and remain in the workforce
for a bit longer that's clear you're not
going to do all that much for most NHS
workers although it might help a little
bit on the margin for some of the Elder
and more senior NHS workers Keen to
bring you in German just a minute but
let's bring let's just ask Charlotte
that question um I don't know if you
heard that from Greg Schneider there was
a little bit of um that the NHS and
pensions actually Charlotte's gone so
maybe we'll speak to her after after but
tell you what we'll do now is we'll
bring in Alan he's calling in from
London and I know Alan you've got an
opinion on terms of the workforce and
this so-called economic inactivity and a
million vacancies which are currently
out there were you cheered by what you
heard today well I think the good news
was that we've had the some model of a
return to what we call in the 1980s
supply side economics we've had a lot of
economically inactive people some of it
was down to the um the lifetime pension
allowance
which discouraged people
from continuing to work and that's
really unfortunate because some of the
some of the most productive years and
um are towards the end of one's career
and it also impacted a lot of doctors I
know that was certainly a a subject uh
we've been talking about and uh
um we can't afford to see a lot of a lot
more doctors leave and
giving them the possibility of
continuing to uh
um stay for their pension I think is an
important factor so they say well a 55
is going to be taken away from me in tax
what's the point of me continuing to
work I understand that and also I think
the the fact that they're allowing um
they're incentivizing
um people who are at home with children
to get back in the workforce is also
very very important we need to increase
the supply of labor we have shortages of
Labor we have shortages of we've had
shortages of good but certainly
um those measures that he took today
incentivizing work uh the workforce to
to get back into uh uh into the dubs I
think is very important
um also we need to make sure that the
older people are at work so that they
can pass on their knowledge to the
younger generation without that
um you know how are we going to get I
think that continuity Alan good point
thank you very much so a positive note
there from our caller Alan in terms of
the these measures to try and get more
people back into the workforce Gemma
will they work do you think and I think
the challenge is is that during the
pandemic we saw a lot of people fall
outside
um you know out of the workforce because
there were illnesses there were people
that were laid off there were people
that became carers for family members
and one of the issues if we look at you
know talking about public sector jobs is
um while the pension reform is great for
as we said you know older doctors to
stay it's not going to solve the supply
issue that we need to get more younger
more people to be attracted to the
industry to start their careers because
one of the issues that we heard earlier
on is that people's working conditions
are just awful it's not just they want
more money to go on holiday absolutely
not it's not just money to be able to
survive it's also the ability to have
more people in the industry so that
people can take breaks so that people
can actually you know there's enough
capacity to look after patients
adequately
um but also not causing a big mental
illness mental health strain I think on
a lot of doctor nurses that are
completely overworked that have been
since the pandemic it's a real I think a
systematic issue okay Gemma thanks very
much Alan they're focusing on the over
50s very important part of the workforce
so our next caller Benjamin completely
at the other end of the scale Benjamin
you're at Newcastle University I know
that you're definitely one of our
younger callers tonight welcome to you
uh what are your thoughts and concerns
this evening regarding the budget
um well I'm a student I I've applied for
a maintenance loan I get the maintenance
loan and the next lump sum is about to
come in at the end of April
um but there's no there's been no
measures there to help with that
increasing with with inflation it stays
the same despite the increase with
inflation so despite the the great hits
of the budget that helped with child
care and and the the energy and stuff
there's nothing really that is aimed at
students like me who have a maintenance
loan there's nothing to help them really
that I can see
um with the coming months perhaps I
understand that the chancellor said that
inflation will go down in the long run
but in the short run there really isn't
anything that I can see helping me with
my mentions
are you feeling overlooked Benjamin
um Overlook perhaps perhaps because
students generally don't vote
conservative perhaps they don't know I
don't know but it doesn't help me really
okay well let's let's get some views
Benjamin for now thank you so much I
mean again students and you know student
maintenance loans not mentioned at all
in the budget this time around no so I
mean to the extent the students are more
likely to be less well paid at the
earlier stages of their career of course
we have seen an increase in the minimum
wage so to the extent that either
students are expecting to be earning at
the minimum wage when they enter the
workforce or maybe are earning at the
minimum wage as part of a part-time job
while they're studying they're at least
going to benefit from the cost of living
the inflationary increase to minimum
wage levels but no nothing else today
for students in a direct sense that's
right I think what was
hear anything about apprenticeships you
know they have been talked about
previously and they're such a fantastic
way to get people into the workforce and
give them a job real life training in
certain areas where we need certain
skills you know moving away from more
academic to much more Hands-On practical
skills to fill the gaps that we have at
the moment in our Workforce and so that
would have been a little bit more
welcoming unless you're over 50 and then
they want you to go back yes which I
think is fun
we'll talk about in a moment but first
let's um welcome Colette she's calling
from Nottingham this evening Colette
welcome to the program great to have you
on board I know that you are a small
business owner or you're involved with
small businesses so did you hear
anything on that front that you were
happy about or not happy about
um well there's a couple of things I
heard really and one just touching on
what you just mentioned there and
firstly I work for the hair and barber
Council
um we're the well non and de facto
regulator for the hair and beauty
industry
um the budget was incredibly
disappointing um I didn't hear small
business mentioned once I sat with my
hand in my head in despair
um you know we've been disregarded for
October disregarded in cost of living
Christ and disregarded again employees
in our industry are near extinction
because we have an unlevel playing field
huge amounts disguise employment and no
enforcement and this is also put
thousands upon thousands of
apprenticeships at risks and thousands
out of jobs the second thing is they
talked about smart regulation for AI
which is brilliant however we currently
have a sector of an underground Market
that's absolutely been allowed to
flourish through covert is huge and we
have absolutely that if you know this
but the hair and Barbara and Beauty
sector is not regulated so anybody can
cut your hair use chemicals that aren't
actually including the poisoning act and
inject you in a kitchen but yet we'll
regulate AI but we won't regulate things
that can actually harm the consumer or
worse
Colette I can hear you you're very cross
I can hear your frustration so that's uh
yeah no and and fair enough okay Gemma
Greg let's bring you in now um Greg I
think Jeremy you spoke lasted Greg to
you me really good points from Colette
then and again not much about not call
about big business right big investment
investment zones and the likes what
about smes because smes as we know the
likes of Colette they are the backbone
of the British economy aren't they well
so the only good news is slightly
insulated from that Rising corporation
tax so if you're paying if you're if
your profits exceed quarter of a million
your corporation tax will rise all the
way to 25 effective April smaller
businesses are more insulated from that
corporation tax rise but apart from that
no this was not particularly a budget at
least as I understood it that was aimed
at those small business owners and
operators
um and so there are those operators are
facing very significant pressures as as
we hear yeah okay Colette well we wish
you well for the future do you keep in
touch and let us know how you're getting
on uh because we're going to move on now
to talk about pensions and support for
older people we've talked a lot already
tonight about the focus we've seen today
on scrapping the lifetime allowance
designed to keep experienced
professional workers in the workforce
namely talking about NHS doctors but of
course the number of them is
proportionally small what about the
wider pension uh demographic in this
country was there anything for them well
John is calling in now John you're from
Norfolk you're 73 years old I hope you
don't mind me telling everyone your age
um
good evening well I can tell you my age
as well if it makes you feel any better
I'm not far behind you
um
what did you think of today's budget
what thoughts do you have well just one
of the things he said I'd like to know
what happened to the triple lock on
state pensions um it was canceled last
year and we would like to believe it was
being reinstated this year but no
mention of it today has it been canceled
again or has it been conveniently
forgotten right let's get straight to
that Gemma what is going on No Gain No
mention of it no mention it was
temporarily dropped but it's actually it
was reinstated at the last budget so
that's good news and just to help
everybody out so that the triple lock
means that the state pension will
increase by the higher of either two and
a half percent the rise in wages or the
rise in inflation and the government
said last time that it would rise with
inflation which is really really good
news so actually in this case no news is
good news
okay that's right so so that's right so
State Pension recipients are going to
see an inflationary increase that's a
CPI increase in their state pension
rates as our Universal Credit recipients
so there are a couple of communities who
are I think favorably treated by today's
announcement there's no bad news for
those groups those are the expected
levels of those Rises okay John thanks
for coming on I hope that answered your
question we're going to go straight to
our next call and our Martin uh he's
joining us uh and mostly understand
you're on happy with government support
for veterans I mean they were mentioned
weren't they but maybe not enough tell
us your thoughts
[Music]
didn't say how long that was actually
over which works out about 16 pounds per
veteran which is just laughable and for
myself I was receiving the lower
standard of occupation I was given three
days notice and now losing 75 pounds a
week on my War pension
just because of some sort of clerical
Arrow or something I don't know but I
was given three days notice to say I was
going to lose 75 pounds a week and now
that's happened today
and that is a that is a huge amount of
money 75 pounds a week I mean let's see
if we can get you some help Gemma what
would you like to say I mean you know I
don't have any help to for that specific
reason apart from just you know
recommending to go and speak to somebody
because that sounds as you said a
clerical error and it sounds like it
shouldn't really okay it shouldn't be
going on but I do I do think you know
veterans were mention the budget but
again this is where headline is being
confused with actually the detail on a
pragmatic level a number sounds really
big the amount of money that they're
going to be using to support veterans
but the way it trickles down
um there isn't enough Clarity on that
how it's really going to help people I
mean they mentioned help with housing
yeah but what about you know people that
need much broader help than that
yes yes all we know is 33 million pounds
uh which is going to be towards a
housing fund but we don't know the
details that's right okay all right
Martin well thank you and we wish you
the best of luck do keep in touch as
well and then you can we can do then do
to keep in touch we're going to move on
now to speak to Jerry Jerry's calling in
from Northwest London uh and Jerry what
is your situation if you don't mind
telling us and what did you think of
today's budget we all actually those
pensioners my husband will be 73
tomorrow and myself 73 next month and we
have custody of two of our young
grandchildren
we didn't think very much of the budget
at all I find it extremely confusing
because we had a letter from the DWP two
two three days ago to tell us that
we would not be getting
the basically not in these words but we
wouldn't be getting the pension rise
because it will be deducted from our
pension credit
this morning we got a letter saying that
our pension credit isn't going to change
so that's confusing us and the other
thing that affects us very much
especially as we've got two young
children here is the energy thing we're
told that energy prices are coming down
for the big companies the big companies
are causing calling Energy prices
um cash machines for them
and we're told that we have to continue
paying this rate even though the prices
are coming down because they block fire
their energy in advance so if that is
true when the prices start to go up why
do our prices go up immediately when by
their own say so they're blocked buying
and they've still got that at the
cheaper price you know for people
you have hit a question or a point that
I've heard many times and it's a very
very valid one and that's of course the
difference in wholesale Energy prices
and Enterprises that consumers pay quick
to go up less quick to come down I mean
what do you think Gemma do you think
that as inflation Falls and energy
prices fall we will see uh house prices
or Energy prices I should say fall
quickly two or not well I think the big
issue is over the next few months um
people are going to see their bills go
up by 67 pound a month so people are
going to see it go up because that
energy support is being taken out so the
fact that the cap is being frozen but
actually the support is being taken out
means that people are going to be here
for the next few months then of course
as the prices go down we would hope that
it would feed through that these things
happen as a lag we see that in Banks as
well you know interest rates rise they
don't necessarily follow on by offering
people better savings rates but they
will charge you more for your mortgage
so you know there will be a lag and I
think people will be squeezed in the
meantime shocked I tell you shocked the
businesses should access cynically I
mean look there's something else going
on here around Energy prices which is
which is complicated and a bit strange
but it's really important to call it out
which is the off-gen the energy sector
sector regulator is actually
discouraging energy companies right now
from aggressively competing on price
because they want to make sure that
there are no more failures of energy
companies right we saw all those
companies fail when the wholesale Energy
prices spiked and companies like bulb
and so on went under so offjam has
actually implemented a scheme to
discourage Energy prices from
undercutting each other that might
stabilize the market but the effect of
that on private individuals is actually
that as prices come down in the
wholesale markets it's less likely that
we're going to see aggressive price
competition in the energy markets for
retails for retail buyers for end
households so there's a real tension
here should we be solving for stability
in the energy Market or should we be
trying to bring down household prices as
fast as possible I would argue off gems
not doing enough here now that's not to
do with the budget but it is to do with
the way the energy is regulated in this
country okay Jerry thank you so much for
your call we wish you luck and also a
happy birthday to your husband for
tomorrow uh let's bring in Hillary now
calling from Lincolnshire Hillary tell
us your situation we I believe that you
are well forgive me are you a pensioner
or not you have to let me know and that
you feel that you're worse off now than
before the budget is that right
um yes I'm a pensioner and yes uh well
I'm going to be worst off from the 1st
of April without a doubt and I don't
believe that the um the budget today has
made any
uh help for me at all in any way
um if I can just
um say
um a moment earlier you were talking
about the increase in the pension
um by 10 which is great but now I've
been put into the tax bracket
um above the personal allowance which
means I'm going to pay 80 pound a month
in tax so I'm you know 20 pounds a month
worth of before I even start and that's
not including
um you know all the price Rises with
food the shopping and the gas and
electric I mean my gas bill has gone up
from 43 pounds to now 139 now the
government's paying part of that but
they're withdrawing the help from that
as well
so everything for me is just going
downwards really
um and I continually will people talking
about disposable income what disposable
income I haven't got any left it's all
gone yeah
which is tough which Hillary it's very
very tough um Jimmy you're nodding as
well in agreement because that's Hillary
absolutely I think Hillary has just
described very aptly yeah exactly the
problem which is people are spending
more so prices are rising
but you're being dragged into spending
more and being charged more on tax
because if your state pension does go up
and you suddenly are in a higher tax
bracket then you're being taxed more and
so this is the income squeeze that
really hasn't been addressed in the
budget okay Hillary we wish you well
let's bring in Maisie very briefly or
our last caller Maisie from
Hertfordshire tell us um what you
thought about the budget today and how
you're doing individually
really have to be honest I didn't see
the whole of the budget so
um that's the first thing to say
secondly
um I I really do I always come from a
point of gratitude because I think as
sort of living with little most of my
life and anything that comes my way I'm
very thankful for
um I'm 69 and I realized last year that
I'm gonna have to go back to work to
make this situation work because it's
either that or I'm gonna have to give up
my home
um I try not to move back with my kids
because I don't think they'd be terribly
happy about that and I wouldn't blame
them
um but it's it's really going to be a
case of going back to work because
um I get two pension payments a month uh
amounting to 740 and
we appreciate your views thank you so
much for joining us on this program and
the best of luck as well for the future
that is sadly all we've got time for
thank you to Greg and Gemma for your
expertise you've been fantastic and of
course all of you called in to have your
say do you stay with us here on Sky News
full coverage analysis of the budget
throughout the evening coming up next
it's Sky News tonight
foreign
[Music]